what's up with those alien bodies
presented to the Mexican
congress with Scientists putting on
display what they claim are the remains
of two extraterrestrials this in Mexico
put on display what they claim are two
alien corpses but not everybody's
convinced
[Music]
so officially these alien bodies
presented in Mexican Congress were found
in Peru and the nska plains of Peru this
is a famous area where there patterns
drawn in the ground where if you're down
on the ground you you can't so there're
just markings in the thing you have to
get high above before you see that there
are huge diagrams that are there some
are straight lines and some very
inventive and imaginative people imagine
those as runways for Ancient Aliens
planes the NASA planes have been a hot
bed of speculation for visiting aliens
of distant past uh so um so the so the
these alien bodies presented to Mexican
Congress are described having been found
in that region of Peru by the way just a
few days ago I received an official
invitation to
Mexico to look at these two alien bodies
personally an official
invitation and I
declined for a very simple reason I I
but I'd love to see the aliens but if
you're going to make an official
invitation to a scientist that
invitation should not go to an
astrophysicist
it needs to go to a biologist in fact it
needs to go to 10
biologists
biochemists invite them 10 of them five
of them any more than three okay they
all come and they each take home a
sample of the bodies of the alien bodies
that's how you do this because that's
how science Works science works not by
one person declaring one result from
their one experiment
no not even from their two experiments
objective truths are established when a
person brings forth the result those
results are shared it could be data it
could be tissue samples it could be
whatever there or explicit instructions
on how to reproduce what you did they're
shared with other Laboratories
regionally and around the world when you
get
agreement in the results then you have
establish lished a new objective truth
that's why I've said the bumper sticker
version of that is the good thing about
science is that it's true whether or not
you believe in it by the way it's also
true whether or not you swore to tell
the truth about it all right scientific
truths are not established by you
swearing that what you're saying is true
nothing could be less relevant to
establishing us you know what else is
not relevant what your pedigree is I
don't care how many stars and bars are
on your
epulet I that doesn't matter what
matters is your experiment do you
realize in my
field published research papers have the
names of the authors almost all of them
are collaborations today the names of
all the authors and your degree is not
included next to your
name so that phds Master's level people
undergraduates
high school students people who are
senior heads of laboratories on a
research paper you're all equal because
if you it's a tacid recognition that if
you have a great idea that idea can come
from anybody at any time and I was not
among them but I I have fellow
undergraduates who did real good
research on a summer project got their
name on a research paper your title and
your academic pedigree is irrelevant
when establishing what is objectively
true in the world if those two alien
mummies are
real its reality is not established by
the sworn testimony of who presented
them nor is it established by anything
he says about
them it's established by sharing your
data with other
Laboratories especially skeptical other
Laboratories okay to my knowledge that
hasn't happened yet so we have an
authentic level of skepticism oh by the
way the rules I'm describing here we
follow these rules for less than aliens
okay that we we have obscure scientific
results that you don't care about the
Press will never write about yet they're
still held to the standards that I'm
describing so you know if you're pulling
out aliens out of your out of your
closet that
the rules that we apply to any other
scientific claim you're making they're
definitely going to be applied to these
and to to quote Carl Sean an
extraordinary
claim requires extraordinary
evidence the claim is that what is there
are aliens not of this
Earth so we better have extraordinary
evidence for
it
so what you want to do is create get
tissue if they're mummified there's
still tissue samples there all right if
it's if it was once living tissue
they're clearly dead now take tissues
all right you can afford to do this the
they're not very big they're like 3T
tall something like that in their in
their little transparent coffins but
take tissue send it out to Labs all
around do that let other people who you
don't even know but have established
laboratory practice is test that
tissue okay that's what you should
do if that comes through and we get
verification now we're
talking and they're aliens not cuz you
swore they were aliens they're aliens
because the scientific method
established that fact and what is the
scientific method I'll tell you uh do
whatever it takes to not fool yourself
into thinking something is true that is
not or to thinking something is not true
that is is whatever it takes that is the
scientific method period if it means
getting chart recorders if it means not
using your suceptible mental state to
establish the reality get other
Witnesses but ideally make get machines
to make the measurement because machines
don't care whether they had coffee this
morning whether they were awake they
don't get sleepy on the job they the
machines and then get another machine
made by somebody else to make the
measurement yeah because maybe your
machine is faulty maybe the wall current
you plugged it into had a glitch this is
what you so that you're not fooled
that's the only thing the scientific
method requires of us so I was delighted
to see the two alien buddies come out
now I have other issues which I'm happy
to share with you but I'm done speaking
about this in terms of the scientific
method if this is life from another
planet
they look awfully human oh my gosh so
early Hollywood aliens they would you
know give them like three eyes or you
know
antennas but it was still an actor in a
costume
walking you know and they have head
shoulders arms legs fingers hips thighs
legs and feet the Cals and feet so
occasionally an alien was more creative
than that keeping in mind if it comes
from another planet it got it's got to
look at least as different from humans
as any two other life forms on earth
look from each other is that asking too
much all right so one of my favorite
aliens was the blob 195 I think it was
remade later but in 1958 Steve McQueen
one of his early movie roles the blob
was it fell from space on it like a
meteorite it was a blob the movie was
aptly named it was a blob and it started
out with no color it was transparent and
then it like attacked you and after it
consumed its first victim The Blob was
red for the rest of the movie you might
forget it started out with no color
there's nothing on earth like that good
alien really really good alien okay how
about alien versus uh how about uh the
movie Predator that was an alien but
wait a minute that alien was
approximately human size it had eyes a
mouth arms it used shoulder mounted
weapons that
knees it's an actor in a costume oh you
give it a weird face okay all right
surely you can do better than that if he
comes from another
planet if you realize we have DNA in
common with a
banana and we look really different from
a banana so if you're going to bring in
an alien from another planet make it
look more different from humans and a
banana than humans and a banana look
from each each
other that's all I'm asking of you so
these Mexican aliens okay they had a
head shoulders arms legs hips uh
femur they had hands oh they had three
fingers instead of five okay all right
and another curious fact they're so
humanoid with the they had two eyes and
nose and a mouth but wait a minute if
you're mummified and you want to be that
human there is no bone structure
underneath your nose look at any skull
look at any mummified thing it's there's
a gap there yet these aliens had these
little tiny little pointy
noses so all right so maybe these aliens
have a bone nose nose bone okay I I
guess so to the extent that it was just
[Music]
fakery what betrays the
fakery is how human they look
look let me just put it that way if
you're going to fake an
alien and make it
convincing do better than that oh one
last thing o o alien comes and says take
me to your
leader don't take him to any leaders no
don't do that don't go to the white
bring him to me all right no but take
him to the National Academy of Sciences
this is what you do to people who will
know how to think about who it is that
just ask that question or better yet
take the alien to Comic-Con they'll feel
right at home as they look at all the
other
aliens that way when they go back home
they'll say you know those humans
they're just like us that's a A View
from Above Cosmic perspective on the
Mexican aliens as always keep looking up
especially for the
aliens